the age-old scientific myth that spider
silk is stronger than steel is coming
down to the wire in their initial
small-scale test 500 strands of spider
silk proved to be twice as strong as its
steel equivalent and now the Mythbusters
are ready to take this test to an
unprecedented scale to test the strength
of a 28 gauge steel wire to its matching
equivalent in density a whopping 25,000
strands of spider silk collected from 42
spiders over the course of five weeks
this is quite possibly the largest
amount of spider silk that's ever been
brought to bear on a test like the one
we're about to do to compare this to the
strength of steel of the same mass why
go to this length it's a great question
the fact is is when you're testing stuff
in scale as long as you iterate you can
come to some good conclusions but the
best way to get great results is to
experiment in the largest scale you can
hence this monster and for this final
silk versus steel smackdown the team has
adapted the test rig with a clever
addition with our new rig here we'll be
connecting two different experiments the
first with our length of steel twine
here with our water being released in a
controlled manner down to this bottom
tank here and it will weigh down that
cable until hopefully it'll sever and
we'll be able to see how much weight in
water is causing that thing to snap if
the results of the previous test hold
true I'm pretty sure that spider silk is
gonna kick Steel's but cue the
butt-kicking attempt the 28 gauge wires
up first steel wire test in three two
one they've traded out washers and paper
clips for over 40 pounds of water it's
so amazing it's so quiet gravity does
its job and as the water trickles into
the lower bucket the steel wire starts
to suffer from some serious water weight
gain its wow look at that it's really
moving its stretching it's visibly
moving that is crazy
I heard a noise that was fantastic that
couldn't be a better result
all right let's weigh this puppy twelve
point five pounds cannon that's a result
let's set up for spider something
definitely 25,000 strands to be exact
Rico it's a nice yellow color I'm gonna
let it take on the weight this is the
most amount of spider silk that's been
tested in this kind of test maybe ever
nine and a half miles of silk right
there that's crazy
nine and a half miles that's insane
you guys already totally yep twenty-five
thousand strands of spiders soaked in
three two one releasing the water court
by Court it's now stretched about a full
edge the 25,000 strands of silk bears
the load okay we've passed the weight of
the steel whoa the silk has surpassed
the Steel's holding power we're coming
up on double but the strain of the
weight is taking its toll
huh what was that that was inside snacks
whoa
[Music]
that's result oh man that was cool
that was fantastic
all right our steel wire held 12.5
pounds this is the amount of water it's
equivalent in mass and spider silk held
and it is cue the drumroll 26 so cool
aren't you excited yep give me a high
five we are so psyched can you tell just
as it did in the previous density
equivalency test the spider silk proved
to be a little more than twice as strong
as the steel to head-to-head density
tests - almost identical results a
satisfying conclusion this classic
scientific myth this is definitely one
of my favorite stories this season no
fire no bomb bass just nine and a half
miles of spider silk and a set of really
elegant methodologies for testing its
strength and you can picture in your
head what a fine steel wire feels like
like jewelers wire you can feel that
okay now I want you to hold that in your
head and watch this this is this is so
gossamer it is barely even there and the
idea that it held twice as much weight
as the steel wire mind-blowing
alright Mythbusters it's time to call
this one from a mass perspective in a
tensile strength test is it true that
spider silk is stronger than steel how
do you find well I mean it tested twice
as strong consistently so I would say
confirmed confirmed confirmed confirmed
it is all right Thank You spiders Thank
You spider no spiders were harmed during
the filming of this episode